la journée mondiale du handicap alors
est-ce que vous le saviez ou pas un
français sur 6 étant situation de
handicap après le cominer un terminal
ministériel qui s'est tenu cette semaine
en présence d'Elizabeth borne nous avons
choisi d'en parler ce midi sur Europe 1
avec des témoignages des questions des
espoirs et des réponses attendues de
votre part bonjour jeunes Darius sec
bonjour alors merci d'être avec nous en
studio ce midi sur Europe 1 vous êtes
depuis quelques mois à peine un ministre
délégué auprès du ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées chargées justement
à des personnes handicapées vous avez
devant vous un énorme chantier j'ai lu
que l'une de vos priorités c'était la
simplification vous allez m'expliquer
comment dans un instant mais avant cela
je voudrais vous faire écouter un papa
Jérôme son fils Kilian a 10 ans il est
poli handicapé toute la famille a
organisé sa vie autour de lui comme sa
maman par exemple qui arrêtait de
travailler et toutes ces démarches
administratives sont autant de temps
perdu à s'occuper de leur fils
toujours se battre il faut remplir des
dossiers des dossiers et des dossiers
nous la simplification on ne l'a pas vu
on a la même l'impression que c'est de
plus en plus compliqué qu'on nous
demande des dossiers et des dossiers de
refaire des choses on nous demande de
fournir des documents les 12 derniers
mois de versement de CAF les six
derniers mois de salaire les nations à
chaque fois c'est des dossiers à non
plus finir donc la simple publication
administrative n'a que voit le jour pour
le handicap ce serait pas mal c'est un
beau chantier prioritaires la
simplification vous en avez parlé oui
parce que ce que vient de décrire ce
papa est la situation que tout le monde
me décrit sur le terrain
et il est vrai que les choses sont très
complexe
il y a eu des améliorations quand même
dans les cinq dernières années avec par
exemple les droits à vie pour certaines
personnes en situation de handicap qu'il
faut un dossier une fois et donc leur
droit sont ouverts à vie mais nous avons
encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir
des simplifications ne pourront venir
que avec une évolution des systèmes
informatiques de toutes les maisons
départementales
du handicap enfin des personnes
handicapées et c'est un chantier qui est
important qui est porté soutenu avec la
Caisse nationale la CNSA et voilà donc
nous allons avancer nous avons bien ces
objectifs et je dois dire que le
dites-nous le une fois doit aussi
s'appliquer aux personnes en situation
de handicap même s'il y a bien sûr pour
certains des évolutions qui
nécessiteront de revoir des dossiers à
reprendre des dossiers sans long et
lourd qui sont des vrais boulets pour
les familles et ça nous en sommes tout à
fait conscient alors autre chantier très
important et là c'est Nabila qu'on va
écouter elle a eu un accident de voiture
il y a quelques années elle est
désormais en fauteuil roulant électrique
mais son appartement n'est pas adapté
mon handicap ça fait 7 ans je l'ai
accepté je suis pas gêné par le regard
des autres j'ai dépassé complètement
tout ça mais je suis empêché par des
aspects administratifs purement
administratifs un logement certain c'est
par la MDPH qui met des années à leur
répondre donc ils ont pas de fauteuil et
c'est ça qui est quand même gravissime
c'est à dire que mon état se dégradé
alors qu'il n'avait pas de raison de se
dégrader alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
mettre la pression sur les bailleurs
quand vous entendez Nabilla cette jeune
femme
bien écoutez il y a bon déjà il y a des
possibilités pour les les bailleurs
d'avoir des soutiens pour adapter les
logements
dans la loi Elan 20% des logements
doivent être totalement accessibles pour
les nouveaux logements construits et les
80 % autres doivent être adaptables
c'est-à-dire que si une personne en
situation de handicap devrait rentrer
dans ce logement ils doivent être
adaptés sans aucune difficulté et sans
gros travaux donc ça c'est une chose qui
est importante mais il est certain que
que un effort considérable doit être
réalisé pour que les personnes en
qui qui porte un handicap physique
puisse effectivement
avoir des logements adaptés alors ma
primadapte va être une aide conséquente
mise à disposition justement de ces
adaptations et nous ferons quand tout
cela aura démarré un bilan régulier afin
de de réorienter si nécessaire cette
politique mais il est vrai que avoir un
toit et un toit accessible et adapté
au-dessus de sa tête est absolument
primordiale c'est absolument capital
alors pour prolonger un petit peu cette
réflexion autour du handicap et des
fauteuils roulant notamment il y avait
hier à Paris la journée paralympique
c'était la toute première organisée au
monde et on a une question de Jonathan
hiverna alors je ne sais pas si vous le
connaissez mais il est capitaine de
l'équipe de France de rugby en fauteuil
j'aimerais lui demander en trois
consiste la réforme autour de l'accès
donc au matériel motorisé et non
motorisé quelle est la réelle volonté en
fait de vouloir changer ce système ça
touche vraiment une infime partie des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
ont besoin vraiment d'un accès vraiment
très spécifique à ce type de matériel
qui est assez coûteux on a tous
conscience mais c'est comme si on nous
enlevait pleinement notre moyen
d'expression de pouvoir
matériel de plus en plus sophistiqué oui
les prises en charge ne sont pas
satisfaisantes pour ces matériels et
nous travaillons avec le
la sécurité sociale la Caisse Nationale
d'Assurance Maladie pour justement que
toutes ces aides techniques puissent
être prises en compte et plus de façon
d'une meilleure façon je vais dire pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
et notamment qui ont besoin de ces
matériels qui sont pour beaucoup
innovants d'ailleurs très performants
très performant et qui vont qui peuvent
changer radicalement et faciliter leur
vie alors nous travaillons actuellement
à faire évoluer ses prises en charge
alors il y a un autre domaine dans
lequel vous inscrivez un peu dans la
continuité complètement à un même de
Sophie Cluzel c'est de poursuivre
l'inclusion à l'école 430 000 enfants
handicapés 320 000 en 2017 sont à
l'école qu'on appelle ordinaire ils ont
besoin d'aesh on va découvrir ce métier
avec un reportage de Luis salé et vous
me direz si vous le voulez bien si vous
comptez revaloriser surtout augmenter
leur nombre puisque de nombreuses
familles nous disent qu'il en manque
cette année
il est 8h30 la sonnerie retentit et
c'est la course pour Ludivine cheveux
orange lunettes rondes et chemises à
fleurs on la repère de loin elle
gambadent dans les couloirs de classe en
classe c'est vrai que ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie pour Laurence prof
d'anglais la présence de Ludivine est
indispensable je n'ai pas le temps sur
une heure de cours de faire du cas par
cas donc je les prends tels qui sont et
ensuite on dépoussière on décortique et
on fait connaissance avec l'élève le
seul problème de Ludivine ne pas pouvoir
se dédoubler elles étaient quatre à ESH
l'année dernière dans ce lycée elles ne
sont plus que deux mais aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas couvrir déjà tous les
enfants il y en a quatre qui se
retrouvent sans accompagnement quand
même pour elle il y a une explication il
y a une vraie précarité on a un premier
contrat de 3 ans un CD de trois ans
renouvelable une fois avant d'être
sédelisé son contrat irrégulièrement
modifié elle pourrait toucher moins que
le SMIC le mois prochain
alors madame la ministre l'éducation
nationale avait annoncé la création de
4000 emplois d'accompagner d'élèves en
situation de handicap pour cette rentrée
le compte manifestement n'y est pas papa
Ndiaye au ministre de l'Éducation elle a
d'ailleurs reconnu un mardi je pense que
c'était lors des questions au
Gouvernement pouvez-vous déjà dire un
peu aux parents quand la situation va se
débloquer et si elle va se débloquer
bien sûr
c'est vrai que le métier d'aesh est un
métier d'abord essentiel oui pour les
personnes en situation de handicap pour
les établissements scolaires
mais c'est aussi un métier qui
est d'une certaine précarité puisque ce
sont 24 heures en fait ce sont les
heures pédagogiques dans les
établissements qui sont rémunérés donc
nous allons travailler comme si c'était
engagé le président de la République et
la première ministre à faire en sorte de
avec nos partenaires que sont les
collectivités territoriales à faire en
sorte et bien
que c'est le statut de ces personnes
évoluent qu'elles aient plus d'heures et
que arrivé à 35 heures et donc un emploi
qui soit un emploi classique et je crois
que les besoins sont importants donc ça
c'est une première chose et le travail
est en est en cours et j'espère que nous
allons évoluer alors il est vrai aussi
qu'il manquait les recrutements des aesh
a été complexe par ce statut bien sûr
par aussi le fait que l'emploi est quand
même des offres d'emploi sont nombreuses
dans notre pays dans beaucoup de
domaines donc c'est une vraie difficulté
parce que des familles se sont
retrouvées sans solution personnelle
mais je veux dire aussi que il faut que
notre regard soit aussi différent sur ce
sujet
je ne crois pas aujourd'hui il ne faut
pas croire aujourd'hui que une personne
un enfant avec un handicap
doivent avoir systématiquement un aesh
ce qui n'est pas le cas d'ailleurs non
ça dépend c'est du cas par mais
évidemment parce que certaines
handicaps ne nécessitent pas un
accompagnement humain il nécessite un
accompagnement par des outils
particuliers ou par une pédagogie
particulière donc tout ça est tenant
ensemble nous devons vraiment évaluer
cette c'est ce travail qui est fait dans
l'éducation nationale parce
qu'aujourd'hui 430000 enfants en
situation de handicap 132
000 aesh ce sont les chiffres c'est
important donc évaluer si et bien cela
correspond aux besoins des enfants et
puis continuer de travailler à à former
les professeurs continuer de travailler
à mieux former les aesh aussi parce
qu'elles ont peut-être ils ont peut-être
des temps de formation qui ne sont pas
suffisants et de mettre en
correspondance les besoins des enfants
et des familles et les besoins de de
l'éducation nationale pour accompagner
merci beaucoup madame la ministre on
aura encore des tailles des tas de
questions pourraient passer beaucoup de
temps avec vous à parler du handicap il
y a une journée le 3 décembre d'ailleurs
donc on aura peut-être l'occasion de
reparler ensemble merci en tout cas